this week we may have witnessed the
biggest chess drama in recent memory
last sunday magnus carlsen a candidate
for the greatest chess player of all
time finally lost the game to a 19 year
old american who has risen to the top of
chess at a phenomenal speed it sounds
like a fairy tale but he's been accused
of cheating things got ugly things got
really crazy and things aren't over yet
all right before we get into this i've
got exciting news for you guys three
words we have merch if you go to the
description box below you'll find a link
to our merch page where we have a whole
load of new merch items for you to check
out my favorite is a hoodie that simply
says touch grass i love it it's sick go
and check it out see what you guys like
christmas is around the corner not
really but you know what i mean check it
out now if you're not really in the
world of chess you might not really
associate it with drama but this is some
of the biggest drama the community has
seen in years let me set the scene the
singfield cup is a big chess tournament
held annually in saint louis in the us
it's part of the grand chess tour a
circuit of tournaments that seeks to pit
the best players in the world against
each other the first singfield cup was
held back in 2013 and was won by a chess
player that even non-chess fans might
have heard about magnus carlsen a lot of
people regard 31 year old karlsson as a
serious contender for the best chess
player of all time the norwegian
grandmaster is a five-time world chess
champion who until recently was on a
53-game winning streak but that streak
ended last sunday when he lost to 19
year old american hans neiman and this
is where the drama begins now neiman is
not an established name in the chess
world by any means his rise to the top
has been meteoric to say the least over
the past few years he'd done well to
make it through the first and second
rounds of the tournament but for the
third round he was to face off against
carlson and that's usually a chess death
sentence nobody seriously expected him
to put a dent in carlson's march through
the tournament he done well to get there
but this was likely the end of the road
but to everyone's surprise the game
didn't go as expected far from it in
fact carlson seemed to make some
uncharacteristically strange moves
before a blunder saw his chances of a
win and even a draw disappear into a
loss
there we have it
wow what a result what
truly
wow i can just imagine the chat
going uh nuts at this point now this was
all obviously a huge shock how did
carson blunder like that how was neiman
so clinical the next day things got even
crazier magnus tweeted out that he had
withdrawn from the tournament something
he had never done before and he added
the famous clip of football manager jose
mourinho being interviewed i prefer
really not to
not to speak
if i speak i am in big trouble now if
you've never seen that clip before it's
something people usually share when
there's something they really want to
say but for whatever reason they can't
people assumed that this was an
implication that neiman had cheated an
accusation which quickly spread one
person who discussed this on stream was
hikaru nakamura an american chess grand
master twitch streamer and long time
rival of carlson i think that magus
believes magnus believes that hans
probably is cheating again unproven
who knows what the reality is he
probably does believe that in its harder
parts that han's cheated in that game or
that he is cheating or whatever okay so
if magnus believes that what is magnus
gonna do in the situation if he really
believes that okay if you go out and you
say something that you have no proof
then you're then like then i mean the
burden proof is extremely high of course
because like if it's not done at a time
when you're at the game of course you
can't prove anything um and so you
really have no way of proving that if
you really believe that
so so i think magnus's way of basically
saying that is like he's not gonna
actually say it but he's putting out
this kept saying if i talk him in
trouble and he's withdrawing to make the
point without publicly making the point
and the sustenance people were feeling
around neiman in general hadn't come out
of thin air he had been accused of
cheating in online games in the past and
had famously been banned from chess.com
in the middle of a stream two years ago
but yeah
i got banned
[Music]
this is probably something i should not
say but i will say this anyway which is
there was a period of over six months
where hans did not play any prize money
terms on chess.com that is the one thing
that i'm going to say and that is the
only thing that i'm going to say on this
topic but it's not just previous bans
that made people suspicious of neiman's
win over carlson there was a lot of
technical chess involved too for example
one of the points that came up was how
neiman claimed he was able to counter
carlson's g3 nimzo opening by
remembering a time when he played it at
a different tournament now some said
carson had never done this but others
showed neiman might just have got the
tournament name wrong and had in fact
seen this before now frankly a lot of
these chess details do go over my head
but there's a lot of chess channels out
there that break down all the details if
you really want to get stuck in for
everyone else though all you need to
know is that the chess community was
exploding by this point but there were
still some like grand master levon
aronian who called for giving niemann
the benefit of the doubt well i think uh
it's quite often happens when young
players play very well there is all
these acquisitions towards them i've
i mean all of my colleagues are pretty
much paranoid and quite often i was the
one telling them come on guys but neiman
wasn't out of the firing line yet the
next day he lost a match in the fourth
round and gave a post-game interview
about what he thought went wrong at the
end he was asked about carlson quitting
the tournament the interviewer and
hikaru both found some amusement in his
answer i guess that was the only reason
yes you can't think of anything else
that was the only reason that's uh look
at alejandro that's the only reason
[Laughter]
but one question a lot of people are
asking by this point is even if there
were these suspicions of neiman cheating
how exactly did he cheat some of the
theories out there were pretty absurd
that's probably a good one right an anal
bead probably would beat the thing i i'm
serious the engine i
it but probably
i don't know i really don't know like
think about it i don't know either way
the tournament organizers decided to
step up their physical security and add
a 15-minute stream delay this seemed to
indicate they suspected something shady
might be going on but weren't sure
exactly what form it might take tony
rich the tournament's executive director
said these additional security measures
as seen being demonstrated here on
neiman himself were a way to ensure the
integrity of the game although he made
no link to carlson and neiman's match
but during all this theorizing and
accusations one person we hadn't heard
from was neiman himself on tuesday he
called out hikaru directly on twitter
saying that hikaru has thoroughly
enjoyed watching his interviews and
criticizing every single detail to make
quote frivolous implications he added
that he'd like hikaru to watch his
latest interview and see what he has to
say the interview in question was
conducted earlier that day on the
tournament stream after neiman's round
five match he broke down hikari's
accusations one by one starting with how
he was prepared for magnus's opening
okay first of all the magnus opening
okay now
let's get to get to that so people were
saying that uh there's no idea why i
checked this well first of all you know
people are absolute idiots because the
explanation i'm going to give is going
to make you all look all the top gems
look like total idiots so
the position first of all they said
there was zero game there was a game
check the database there's this thing in
chess called transpositions okay now
when he played the move a3 of course i'm
expecting to move now to three now let's
say in the catalan no let's let's show
it because this is just this is just
embarrassing um this is absolutely
embarrassing now like i said earlier
we're not going to get into the weeds
here with all the chest details the
point is neiman wasn't going to waste
this opportunity to stand up for himself
one of the things he was keen to set
straight was what happened with his
chest.com bands that we spoke about
earlier
so
in some i wanted to gain some rating you
know i just wanted to get higher rates
so i could play stronger players so i
cheated in random games on trust.com now
i was confronted i confessed and this is
the single biggest mistake of my life
and i'm completely ashamed and i'm
telling the world because
i do not want any misrepresentation and
i do not want rumors i have never
cheated in an over the board game
other when i was 12 years old i have
never ever ever and i would never do
that that is the worst thing i could
ever do cheat in a tournament with prize
money now i made that mistake
and this is something i thought
something i was doing consistently never
when i was streaming did i cheat never
did i misrepresent my strength so i made
this mistake i was confronted by
trust.com i had fully admitted and i
stopped playing trust.com nieman also
shared the news that since the
accusations of him cheating began to
spread chess.com had actually uninvited
him from the global championship now
that
chestercom has suddenly decided to hop
on magnus's uh insinuations he carries
very direct accusations now they see the
opportunity okay we're just gonna get
rid of this i believe this is completely
unfair this is a targeted attack and if
you look at my games this is not
it's has nothing to do with my games so
why do you specifically
why do you why does the ceo just come to
me and say we're looking forward to
having the global trust championship
we're looking forward
to you playing on our events and then
right when i beat magnus they decided to
remove my account and not let me play in
the tournaments this is absolutely
ridiculous and they've only done this
because of what magnus has said with
picaroses and that the entire social
media chess world is completely
attacking me and undermining me he was
deeply unhappy at carlson for the
insinuating tweet at chess.com for
removing him from their tournament and
hikaru for his comments on the mata
which he actually addressed in his
thursday stream later on in the video
hans very clearly he uses this word i'll
just say he says directly direct
accusation so he says that i directly
accuse him of cheating now there might
be a youtube video coming out later um
from the vaude the other day
specifically because there are many
instances where i said that he did not
cheat over the board the one thing i did
say was that he did cheat online and he
himself admitted that he did so i want
to be very clear on that that's the
second point when he says direct
accusations i never made a direct
accusation about over-the-board shots
hikari brought up the general suspicion
around neiman due to just how quickly
he's risen to the top over the past
three years um if you if you look at the
history of hans um over the last couple
of years he's had probably the most
meteoric rides in the entire history of
chess um of any 17 year old by far uh if
you look at the other other juniors who
i believe are around like 2 700 ish i
think almost all of them became
grandmasters about 14 15 maybe maybe
some even at 16 but to go from a 24 80 i
am to 27 10 27 20 whatever it might be
in the last two years i think a lot of
grand masters are definitely suspicious
of that it's unprecedented in the entire
history of chess now we're not going to
continue with this back and forth
anymore these videos are out there if
you want to hear everyone's expanded
points but where do we lie now well i
suspect that some people who are on the
fence or even suspected in the evil of
cheating might be leaning the other way
now now that's partly because of the
points he put forward in his interview
but also perhaps it's the fact that some
aspects of this story feel like they
have a bit of a witch-hunt feel to them
bear in mind that no concrete evidence
has come to light yet and these kinds of
allegations can destroy a 19 year old's
career before it even takes off and
perhaps in one final twist chess.com
released a statement yesterday saying
they have shared detailed evidence with
neiman about their decision to remove
him from their events evidence that
contradicts his own statements they say
they have invited him to provide an
explanation so that he'll be able to
participate again so is neiman going to
provide an explanation to chess.com will
it be public and if he gets unbanned or
stays banned from this will this affect
how the carlson match will be perceived
to me this feels like we're on episode 5
out of a seven episode tv series that
has had the chess community absolutely
glued to their seats will other pros get
called out now too this feels far from
over remember we haven't actually heard
anything from carlson yet other than
that cryptic tweet he made a strong
implication that has the potential to
damage someone's career some people feel
that he needs to back that up now and so
we wait and while we wait you can
guarantee that everyone involved in this
saga will be contemplating their next
i used to play chess
at school as a kid
and i remember learning like
the three move checkmate
or four move checkmate or something
and then as soon as everyone figured out
how to counter that
that was it that was the end of my chest
playing career
i was washed up i retired left the scene